Oh got one read my name is pat pat
feared about LS pity does forget about
any have survived
alright so define I was holding a Tom
key term key I don't know what that is
and my screen is purple now because my
[ __ ] there we go
what is this is click it we found the
power says it's in the temple but things
got terribly wrong man if you light some
information should still there the devil
all right I don't know I click at it
twice
[Music]
stop stop don't make me kick your trice
don't stop making me clean ya idiot
heads ow ow what you can go through was
yes that's how I go through your mama's
[ __ ]
what just stop saying that what is up
there put me that there we go
what is this Wow well well done pants
all right let's check this out what I
don't like this
yeah papillae the temple is moved too
dangerous [ __ ] what was that [ __ ] this
[ __ ]
don't worry about fits you will only die
ma what else oh [ __ ] he's fast
look at that I bet they had a period
slide about the spinning they're really
good fun you know came from your mama's
stop Stephano says I gotta leave you
there
oh [ __ ] I'm loving all the papyri over
there it's awesome
anyway steered me in the loading screen
sorry I don't know what happens
sometimes I just Daniel
this can't be good I didn't think it
would be that good
[Music]
Hey hi bow what are you doing in a
temple barrel
no I lags you about my choppa oh come on
I don't even know why I say anymore
ching chong there we go
chip duck Duck Duck
what a hell is this but what now you
made me disoriented stop making me dizzy
hello Wow
alright we'll go there after I go up
here daddy daddy daddy da
god damn ladders so [ __ ] long that's
what she's okay I kind of expect it when
it starts lagging it's a shame
anyway what
oh no the GUI doesn't like me taking
that what is it a star beautiful I take
you with me
you go first sorry I don't even know
what I need this fight s jump badass
nice ass I like it I think I have a
thumbnail right there but all right so
where's the tomb gone this is that
someone may be here
what is this what are you hiding from
your house shut up out goddamn ya wooden
bucket you [ __ ] I don't there we go
not a problem
what do I need with this probably some
weird sacrificial [ __ ] I think I went in
here I should know then the battles
should be destroyed and they're all
intact explain this [ __ ] all right
I don't [ __ ] know we came from that
all right let's go straight then gonna
take what the hell are we
[Music]
what's going on in here
oh it's creepy whoa what is this ah
spend the world panic it doesn't solve
anything
[ __ ] Jesus guys let me look at you
before you hoax then that's what [ __ ]
stop it pity [ __ ] God [ __ ] sleep I
hate when they just boom-boom zoom in
this room
let me give me a break I don't stop
moaning like a [ __ ] I guess we gotta
keep going then huh
god damn it I literally have no idea
what I'm doing right now but do you like
it
can I go in here say it you're not dying
here cowboy
that and there oh hello
oh hello maybe this is like the ending
or something ah this cousin sorry is
pretty [ __ ] it bake I'll take that
let me out Wow I want that stop Wow Wow
Wow
I guess we need to cool it with some
water but we don't have a water let us
find the water take a look at the water
where are you water
[Music]
where is that oh hello no one well
well they well they well maybe on the
sides I never really looked outside what
I come back here on more divorce just
bad news I can't open this because it's
stones are there are they supposed to be
there I want to go inside your bow god
damn it
Godfrey Kerr I'm SuperDuper now I'm just
walking suckered began a chop right now
what in the hell what in the heaven
shut up moaning feet about hash walking
on like an egg but I'm pretty sure I've
been here before
ah but Dad under me we can't be hard to
get there I just want to be friends I
just want open that door I didn't want
to be Oh
why do I find the water but where do I
find the water
no I don't even know where do we find
what
quite a pound am i walking back I think
I welcome back yeah I'm walking back I'm
not gonna cheat or anything but you know
alright so there was water here I just
didn't [ __ ] see it I don't like I'm
at like that alright there we go let's
put it there blah blah
I missed it's kind of hard to miss oh my
god oh all right I'm going I'm God Wow
let's go let's go let's go oh stop
there's that going save some guys to
shield the [ __ ] out - what are you doing
here I will give you a game I'll go here
bounce you're going to Ming
just kidding oh ok I need to go faster
come on now I'm gonna die gonna die I'm
so good alright up good
it's getting dark for kids Wow Jason
Skye's brothers what do I know
what are those people I got okay I hate
you the potion
it's [ __ ] freak as hell
but I still have to run but they told me
to sleep I don't want to sleep
Wow
I don't think that's the right way
all right have we got
shut my mouth might stop you freaking me
out man
okay I'm almost at
if you'd stop winking like a [ __ ]
fine I'm going
how's it hurting me
this is just [ __ ] annoying
okay I'm going Jace's price if you ought
to block the way it would go faster
thank God thank god that's over
all right here we are once again let's
get out of this haunted house hole I
think now we need to put the warp
somewhere I just don't know why I did
the dudes own away [ __ ] temple man
you can't even take orbs these days from
ancient temples without people being
pissed about it
oh that's in computer hello father
now you're AI J such guys fit I hide in
this locker what you were scared I'm
never scalp it's no all right whatever
you saying yep dud question me all right
wallet what is this well I think we need
to go up here
what Wow careful today I don't trust
ventilation systems such as my bathtub
ow
oh [ __ ] [ __ ] I think we'll have to
solder pads I'm in tomorrow say that
don't let about a ped I [ __ ] hate you
but I tried I tried
what is he one minute er hello
I'll get your help tomorrow don't worry
all right which way to go whoa I'm
totally going to get neither shut up
[ __ ] you I'm not gonna fight I'm going
I'm not going I'm going I'm doesn't give
a [ __ ]
fine I'm not taking anything cop down
that [ __ ] [ __ ] I guess I [ __ ]
him I don't give a [ __ ]
it's not gay if you don't like it
alright I might going the hell am I
oh come on goddamn it
I'd suck today
and anyway yeah no oh I didn't think so
now why the hell are we okay we just
have this now well just get out of here
that's pretty cool that's pretty freakin
cool
shup well is that don't even worry about
it what I can't go out now fine I don't
need to go out going out this for now
let's take this door
I don't give a [ __ ] please don't kill me
please don't kill me
I'm friendly all right freeze you're a
toy ah thank you
all right now we can go yeah all right
press gotta end this episode I think
there will be last one in the next one
like a favorite at the end I gotta get
my bread today
- sure
brutality